[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: What was Jude's last name?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I never had one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude the Mysterious.
[SPEAKER_00]: Someday, in the middle of the month of flock time, in the 576th year of the Common Error,
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude, returning from Idee to Monmurg to try and find his friends, well, associates anyway, Gouge and Karmirg, who had abandoned him on Ogmotton and Celeborn Landroval to their fates.
[SPEAKER_00]: In Idee and the southern province.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's on a mission to try and get Karmirg to come back.
[SPEAKER_00]: He doesn't really care about Gouge because Gouge doesn't really care about any of those people.
[SPEAKER_00]: To assist in the war in the southern provinces.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've taken a ship with your henchman, and I think, if I remember correctly, your henchman was called Horace Boltpate?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, I like it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you remember this name?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, I remember Horace.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Horace Boltpate was a guy that actually hung out with you many times.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he hung out with Celeborn too, and he went through some weird times.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, but he was the guy you guys hooked up with in Greyhawk.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, do you remember this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, no, I totally do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and from what you understand, you were never a part of this part of the adventure, but there was some strange necromancy involved.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, your companions, basically on Loth-Ug-Motn,
[SPEAKER_00]: Was a little freaked out by Horace because he said he was killed at one point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, he's with him now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But there's nothing that's ever made me think that somehow he was undead or anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well...
[SPEAKER_00]: He definitely wasn't like... What's his face?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like the Revenant?
[SPEAKER_00]: Vladnag.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's kind of your bar, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're okay with it, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I'm totally fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: But let me know if he's off to pursue some vengeance trip, even if he does look and smell better.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, he does definitely look and smell better than Karmirg.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's another bar that you have.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, you know, he's a human and from the sea, so basically he's a guy that's sailed around and been a traveler.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's probably, I would say, about 40 years old, a little bit past his prime as far as fighting goes, but knowledgeable about the world, and that's what you like about him, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, is he like a certain level of fighter?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's fifth.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's the fifth level fighter.
[SPEAKER_00]: He actually hails from Onwal.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Onwal is like a premier traveling city.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know Onwal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you know Onwal well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's why actually... That's from Scamps, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Aren't they part of the Iron League?
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Onwal, Scant is the city, Onwal is the country, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And Horace Boldpate hailed from there, and actually he met up with you guys when you, way before that, when you guys were in the Pomarj, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because he was sailing around there.
[SPEAKER_00]: But when you met him later in Greyhawk,
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually recruited him to come with you.
[SPEAKER_00]: He basically said, yeah, I'd rather hang out with you because Anlauf Ogmotton and Celeborn have like weird feelings about me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So he's been very useful.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't really, I mean, he's not a Karmirg level fighter.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, of course not, but he's capable of covering my back while I'm cast and made, you know, magic spells on a battlefield.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, more like in an alleyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: More than that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know what I mean?
[SPEAKER_00]: On a battlefield, you know, it's like, you'd want a hundred guys around you, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: One guy wouldn't do much, but, you know, you trust him enough to basically have him hold your bag of coins, is what it comes down to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, and guard my back in an alleyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, totally, totally.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, even in Scant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Scant's a pretty honest city, so, you know, no big deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, just for me, is there anything, like, does he have a family or kids that we're, you know, sending gold home to, or is there anything, like, or is he just complete, sort of, free, you know, unattached?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, so, he's actually been a merchant from Scant, and he may have some extended family, but he does not have a wife and child, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you think he might have some, like, cousins or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's connected in the city, but he's not tied down, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to investigate further or do you care?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I like to, I mean, I'm thinking in terms of knowing who's got my back in an alleyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was never very comfortable with a gal shoving my back.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he's not tight-lipped.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I just think that you figure he doesn't have a lot to say.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, he has some extended family, cousins and whatnot, but he mainly has kind of acted like a merchant in the past.
[SPEAKER_01]: Shipping or land marching?
[SPEAKER_00]: Shipping, mostly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Out of Onwal, it's all ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, the Anwalian Navy is pretty serious, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, um, you know, he's a good, he's a good sailor.
[SPEAKER_00]: He knows how to sail.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's what you really like about him, is the fact that he's been around a lot of the seas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, he picks the ship that we're gonna go back to Monmurg on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, and actually that's the thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like, uh, you, you like the fact that he knows his way around not only the Iron League and the cities around the Iron League, but most ports.
[SPEAKER_00]: A good guy to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it something that I could talk to you more to get us some information about while we're sailing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, let's role-play it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's role-play it, alright?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, basically, what it is, is he has booked passage.
[SPEAKER_00]: You want to go back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he had traveled through Irongate to the city of Scant, and he's gotten you passage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, from Scant to the west.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: And, um, you guys are like hanging out on this boat, this Unwolling Merchant that is going to be taking off in what is late winter to go to Monmurg to trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's got, you know,
[SPEAKER_00]: Lots of goods from, you know, Irongate, which is a big trade city, but also from Nyrand and a lot of Eastern nations.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they're going to trade in Monmurg for Dwarvern metals and steel that come down from the Yeomanry and the Yeotan Mountains because they know there's a good
[SPEAKER_00]: A good market for it there.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, the two of you are hanging out on this Lonwallian Trader and you paid your passage, which is like maybe ten gold coins for the journey and then, depending on what you want, you know, a gold coin per day if you want to live like a noble or a silver coin per day if you want to live like a normal person.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, we'll, we'll share a room.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I don't need, we don't need two separate rooms.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd rather have them.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, um, I mean, I don't want, like, a, you know, rat, I mean, it's a ship, so there's probably rats on it, but, you know, um, a good room.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you know, a fine room where, and you don't mind being with Horace, your servant, and you're, you guys are, like, hanging out.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, this is, like, your first day traveling, uh, to the West.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if you want to ask questions, ask questions.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Horace, did you ever see this ship that Karmirg and Gaj left on?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, yes I did.
[SPEAKER_00]: We saw it together.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you think of that ship?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, he's going reefing, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's going to pirate?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it looked to me like to be a Cossair from the Sea Principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sure he does, actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, I spoke to the Dockmaster and definitely when he collected Karmirg, he was looking for him specifically.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think he's got himself a letter of mark and not one or two rough sailors, I would call them.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what I'm trying to think about, and I need your help a little bit with this horse, because you've sailed all over.
[SPEAKER_01]: It seems to me that, politically speaking, the Great Kingdom, especially through the South Province, the Herzog of the South Province, if they are able to defeat a D, then they cut off the Iron League.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sun D from the Iron League.
[SPEAKER_01]: It'll be cut in two.
[SPEAKER_01]: And even if the northern half can survive, the southern half maybe, but even more importantly, that's going to give the Great Kingdom, through the South Provence, ports on the Azure Sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: Specifically in Nerea, Nerea Falls.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, right now, it seems to me, and I'm not entirely sure, you're from Onwal, but it seems like the Great Kingdom only can get into the Sea of Grenad.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so if they need to be somehow bottled up or try to, you know, be restricted should any larger war break out, it would be coming out of the Sea of Grinant through that, whatever you guys call it, that tighter gap.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not that tight, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: So I guess what I'm wondering is that, in your experience, how well prepared is Anwar to keep
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, does Onwal keep the Great Kingdom out of the Azure Sea?
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, to be true, I don't think the Great Kingdom has much want to go on the sea.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're armies.
[SPEAKER_00]: They don't have navies, per se.
[SPEAKER_00]: Honestly, I think their mind and their eyes go to Nyrand and the countries in between.
[SPEAKER_00]: The South Province and the Herzog wishes to subjugate Idee and Sundee and Irongate and even Onwal, but really, once he gets it, once he takes it, if he ever can, he'll let it rot.
[SPEAKER_00]: He has no care for the sea or the trade we have, just the wealth it can steal from us.
[SPEAKER_01]: I doubt they even think of it, to tell you the truth.
[SPEAKER_01]: What they think about the Great Kingdom is the wealth that they get from the king himself.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Great King will steal wealth from all the lands around him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I know this for true because I see it pass through not only our ports but the ports of Nyrand and other places.
[SPEAKER_00]: These evil traders definitely wish to deal with the Sea Principalities for, in truth, as Onwal is the center of trade for the Eastern Lands, Monmurg is three times that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not only do the western kingdoms trade there, but kingdoms to the south, far beyond the Azur Sea, come there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Foreigners, strange people, so great is the market there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you referring to like also the slave trade coming out of the jungles in the south?
[SPEAKER_00]: I know little of that, but truthfully there are slaves that trade there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Few are bought by my people.
[SPEAKER_00]: Some do go to the Great Kingdom.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, from my understanding, the Toli purchase the lot of them in most cases.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's also my understanding, that was at Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know little of the politics of the Sea Principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: You would know more than I, but from what I understand,
[SPEAKER_00]: Huge number of slaves that are pulled out of the immediate jungle.
[SPEAKER_00]: Most of them stay in the sea principalities, even though some are shipped south.
[SPEAKER_00]: Few make their way to the east.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you ever been, or do you know much of the sea barons?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I do know of the sea barons.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're a powerful force.
[SPEAKER_00]: From what I understand, actually, the sea barons are breakaway Aradians from the sea principalities.
[SPEAKER_00]: Leaving the outer islands maybe 50 or 60 years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm trying to find a reason for Monmurg, maybe not all of the Sea Princes, but at least perhaps Prince Jeon with Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm trying to find a reason for them to maybe want to help.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I'm looking for Karmirg, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm wondering, like, I can't see an angle.
[SPEAKER_01]: The only angle that I can think of is kind of shot down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meaning, you know, to keep the South Province out of the Azure Sea, but if you don't really think that the South Province has any designs on the Azure Sea,
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I'll be honest with you, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: The greatest navy in the world comes from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Their ships have once and again defeated all the other navies of the world.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, their only rival is Gratzl, from Gratzl, from Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: The unwalling fleet is powerful, true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mainly our ships are deep sea traders.
[SPEAKER_00]: And even though we can delve farther and deeper in the oceans than the sea principalities, we're actually quite equivalent as far as that goes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And by the way, they are much better warriors on the sea than we are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know my history.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm familiar with their battles, their sea battles with Keoland.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I see no...
[SPEAKER_01]: I see no reason for them to get embroiled in anything with the Iron League.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I'm worried about is that, like I said, Sudi being like, or Sundi being isolated if the D falls.
[SPEAKER_01]: Onwal and Irongate are strong.
[SPEAKER_01]: They can probably hold out indefinitely.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I can't imagine that Sun D will last too much longer after a D falls.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just don't see an angle on why Monmurg or the Sea Princes...
[SPEAKER_00]: I can see two angles, actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: One is trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Onwal is a wonderful trade partner with Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, I would say we represent at least a quarter of the market that happens in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there is that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, would that be something they'd be willing to fight a war over?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or even finance.
[SPEAKER_00]: Finance, possibly.
[SPEAKER_00]: But truly, from what I know,
[SPEAKER_00]: The Monmurgians love money.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they would have to be trade concessions.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, with the Iron League, I would think overall, even just to have them, you know, help to finance.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, my understanding hitherto is that we have a friend, the Iron League has a friend in Nairon, but Nairon is, are they secure in their fighting against the Great Kingdom?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you know as much as I do, the King of Nairant is a powerful man, and he rallies the forces against the Great Kingdom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why?
[SPEAKER_00]: And, in truth, to be honest, the Great Kingdom is a corrupt and debauched country.
[SPEAKER_01]: Their leaders are insane.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, their king is insane, this is true.
[SPEAKER_00]: But even their lords care more about themselves than they care about war or competency.
[SPEAKER_00]: In truth, their only advantage is mass and the number of men that they command.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now,
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll be honest with you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that even a count in the Great Kingdom has enough men to be able to crush a D if they were loyal to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Harazog too is a powerful man.
[SPEAKER_00]: He has many people that he can command.
[SPEAKER_00]: But these are slaves or peasants that he puts together.
[SPEAKER_00]: If there is a leader that's strong against him, he can definitely be resisted.
[SPEAKER_00]: But Jude, I will tell you this.
[SPEAKER_00]: He is taking advantage of the great wave that destroyed a thee, and that's why that country is in such dire need.
[SPEAKER_00]: Many died in that tsunami.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you remember that tidal wave that came in and destroyed everything, NID?
[SPEAKER_01]: It was destroyed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Naree was destroyed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so was there attempts to even rebuild Nereo over the last year?
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, basically that's kind of what, you know, Paradil has been trying to do, is to get the people to live and be safe and basically rebuild the kingdom.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's most of what his effort's been, and that's been really hard, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you ever traveled to the jungles in, I think it's Amedeo?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Amedeo?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I've never been there.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are near the Great Kingdom, I mean, near the Sea Principalities, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: From what I understand, the Amedeo jungle is... A place where...
[SPEAKER_00]: The Sea Principalities rip resources from... My understanding.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's my understanding?
[SPEAKER_00]: Port Toli is...
[SPEAKER_00]: Port Toli is the place where...
[SPEAKER_00]: They use the Emedio as their place to take wealth from the...
[SPEAKER_00]: The natives and the savages that live there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: My understanding is the slaves largely come from those tribes in the Emidio.
[SPEAKER_00]: And by the way, I'll tell you Jude, the reason that the Sea Princes have such wonderful ships is the woods they find there are amazing.
[SPEAKER_00]: The sailmasters and shipwrights of Monmurg revel in creating ships from that wood.
[SPEAKER_00]: They've made...
[SPEAKER_00]: I will tell you, it's like, there are few forests in the world that can rival what the Amedeo jungle makes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So them having a...
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, in truth, Anlauf Ogmotton makes all of its ships from wood taken from the Meteor Jungle.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's one of the main things we trade with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: What did the Iron League or a D have for trade or for export of value?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, a D has silver and gems.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's good trade there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Some D has foodstuffs and so on.
[SPEAKER_00]: But truthfully, the elven artisans make great things from there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Irongate itself, there are traders from the sea barons in the south that go to Irongate to trade as well, but also, I will let you know that there are many in the Great Kingdom, southern province even, that have black markets in Irongate.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll find that Irongate is much like Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a city of civilization.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are three cities in the Flanness that rival each other in trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're Monmurg, Irongate, and of course, Greyhawk itself.
[SPEAKER_00]: These cities are old, and the families have
[SPEAKER_00]: Wide reach throughout the Flanness.
[SPEAKER_00]: Money finds its way here, as do exotic things.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in no small amount is there an arcane connection.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not saying that the
[SPEAKER_00]: Centures of knowledge are in these three cities.
[SPEAKER_00]: But from what I understand, all three of them are very close to places where Suel families settled.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought Suel mostly in the south.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did they penetrate as far north as Irongate?
[SPEAKER_00]: I've heard that some lost tribes have gone up into the northern province.
[SPEAKER_01]: But there are other whispers.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are other whispers.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually I've heard this from you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Were not the monks that you found in the southern lands, Suel?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's... You whispered to me of the Scarlet Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, all I can say to you is the greatest of Suel families that still exist
[SPEAKER_00]: Are in Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Rola and the Nahili.
[SPEAKER_00]: Both souls that have survived the cataclysms, the twin cataclysms, reside there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that was the Rolas and the Nahili?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Rola and the Nahili.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two families.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know much, Horace.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you had some wine?
[SPEAKER_00]: I could use some.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, I brought a case with me, so... Seamus won't miss a few bottles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, let us drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let us drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you hope to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I've not asked about our journey, but what is your mission?
[SPEAKER_00]: This is quite a journey all the way to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: As much as I loathe being sent on any journey by Philo, I still do it for Paradil.
[SPEAKER_01]: And for Idee.
[SPEAKER_01]: And because Karmirg has really pissed me off in his desertion of the Battles.
[SPEAKER_01]: In his leave-taking with Gouge on their Reavers journey.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to try to find Karmirg.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had kind of suspected that he had a mark, a letter of mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: He needs to come back.
[SPEAKER_01]: His Hillmen are scattered.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're lost.
[SPEAKER_01]: He awoken something in the Iron Hills that's now some
[SPEAKER_01]: Problem with the giants that's now causing them to take their vengeance out on his people for as much as he cares.
[SPEAKER_01]: And now they're coming in as refugees and leaderless.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have to have karma.
[SPEAKER_01]: That and for all of his bluster and fun-loving, carefree attitude, he appears to be a better strategio than
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I will travel to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will treat with Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will ask for the Karma, or at least knowledge if they have a way of keeping in touch with any of their reapers that they send out.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I will
[SPEAKER_01]: I will see if I can interest at least one of the Sea Princes in taking some small part either financially or otherwise with the future of the D. Well in truth I hope you go as an ambassador with promises of money and of trade because that is what they know in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so to the DM, I had asked that if I had any letters of introduction at minimum or if I have any authority to entreat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, so basically you were sent to find, uh, uh, Karmirg.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have an in with Jamis, so maybe discussing politics would be good there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jamis does know who Philo is, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Doesn't like him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: But what you're hoping is that you can kind of, you know, use Gouge and Carmack as a way to sort of negotiate things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, but also, I mean, like, so, I mean, I can ask for a favor just in, so what my thoughts are is I can ask for a favor from Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: For, if nothing else, then to either blackmail or force Karmirg back into the Battles of Idee.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I have some ideas on how to try to create some leverage.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the fact that if they indeed issued letters of marque, that gives me a little bit more leverage.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, potential leverage to try to negotiate.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, if nothing else, if I come back with Karmirg, I don't come back empty-handed.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I'm trying to figure out is that can I make promises
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Onloff is desperate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, basically, what Onloff said to you before you left is, bring him back, please, whatever it takes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, you know, Lord Jamis is probably...
[SPEAKER_00]: He will sell an orc for coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, in fact, I'm saying, like, hey, you can have a state of interest in the future of the D if you just, you know, shackle Karmirg.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the truth is the way Jamis feels about things, you know this, is that if he doesn't need Karmirg around...
[SPEAKER_00]: He would sell him for copper coins, basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: If there's a war on, and he needs them, that's a different matter.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe it's best where he goes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But, you know, if there's a trade deal to be had, Jamis will deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, especially if Karmirg is better used someplace else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, and so that's what I'm thinking.
[SPEAKER_01]: So knowing that Arnloff is desperate, I'm not empowered with any kind of diplomatic in any official capacity.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you are.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely you are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I am?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so that's what I was wondering.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, he's desperate.
[SPEAKER_00]: He'll take whatever he can.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, if you go back with some kind of offer from Jamis,
[SPEAKER_00]: uh... you know that's better than anything and in fact you know the problem is of course what can he offer you know goodwill at this point yeah exactly to jamis great trade negotiations all this stuff great negotiations he can even allow maybe because of the coast we don't know that jamis has much of an interest in uh...
[SPEAKER_01]: So by the way, and you know this, you're smart enough to know this, offering
[SPEAKER_00]: A portage in a D that is defended for Monmurg as a trade port would rival Scant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, you might not want to say that to Horace, but literally it's right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so if you basically said, we'll put a trade port there where you can extend your stuff,
[SPEAKER_01]: Now that would fuck with Unwall because of course Monmurg would want to use that as a place to trade.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, so with Jack with Onwal.
[SPEAKER_01]: But at the same time, have we heard anything from Onwal or Irongate regarding the pleas of the situation over the last year with the D?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, this is the horrible thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's not been that much enthusiasm from those places.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, and we incurred, somehow we incurred, like, the wrath of the Herzog is now bent on the destruction of Idee, all the more so because of Idee's dire straits because of the tidal wave.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, Idee is actually the most vulnerable, and in the history of it, Idee had the most people that were willing to
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, Onwal, you know, the thing is Onwal is isolated and protected by Irongate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Irongate is a great city that has huge fortifications.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sundee is underneath where Idee is.
[SPEAKER_00]: They support Idee and they give troops to Idee, but Idee is the country that bared the brunt.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they're decimated, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, so, what I'm wondering is, I mean, like, we're desperate for everything.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I was wondering is, is that I know that, at least in my readings, and probably because I've been to Monmurg, the Sea Princes have, like, a huge reputation for defensive fortifications.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we have less than one minute.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna schedule another meeting, and we'll go again.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'll send you the email, alright?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, just take a break.
[SPEAKER_00]: It will take five minutes, let me do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, alright, sounds good.
We'll be right back.